what's going on guys in this video i'll
be explaining the fate of best genius in
detail
and what it means for the future of this
series in order to do this i will be
talking about spoilers from my
academia chapter 288 and also a bunch of
manga chapters as well that came before
this
so if you want to avoid spoilers then
yeah this is not the video for you
just before we get into it there will be
no new chapter next week
as horukoshi is taking a well-deserved
break but be sure to sub anyway because
there will be some other videos in the
meantime
okay so chapter 288 kicks off in a
surprising manner
as we see an unknown jet flying through
the sky with two mysterious characters
inside it
inside the jet we see a bunch of carbon
fiber cables which are identical to
those used by best genius
during my hero academia vigilantes minor
spoilers for vigilantes
but in that spin-off we saw a younger
and more sleeveless version of best
genus
using carbon fiber cables to stop this
tower from falling
this type of fiber is normally used for
holding up suspension bridges
and it's incredibly tough but because
it's fiber
genus is able to freely manipulate it
flashing forward to the present day
we hear a man inside the jet complaining
that it's not going fast enough
to which the pilot replies and tells him
to sit down as the mystery man's body
has not recovered yet
whilst we don't get a look at the man's
face we do see a little bit of his body
and you know he has a has a bit of a
slender frame
and also you know the fact that his body
hasn't recovered yet
it almost subtly confirms that yeah best
genus is still alive
as the last time we saw him he was still
recovering from his battle against all
for one
based on the context of certain events
it's highly likely that genus plans to
manipulate these
carbon fiber cables to restrain giganto
machia and
possibly trip him up like the students
did before as with most plans to stop
gigantomachia
this will probably not be able to hold
him back for long
but it may temporarily restrain him and
allow more citizens to be evacuated
before he continues his rampage
now before we move on i'm going to
explain how he's still alive
and then i'm going to give you my take
on why i would have preferred this
not to be a fake death way back in
chapter 231
we saw that debbie asks hawks to prove
his loyalty by killing a pro hero
other than the number one of course
because that honor is reserved for dabi
himself
the scene then progresses to best
geniuses apartment where hawks gives him
a rare visit
knowing what we know now we can examine
this whole interaction in a totally
different light
genus reveals how despite only having
one lung
he plans to resume his hero activities
very shortly
and step back into the public eye hawks
then laughs
and replies by saying that you know
that's too bad this is then followed by
hawks holding a body in a bag
as he says the words don't let a
person's resolve go to
waste knowing that genus wanted to
shortly return to his hero activities
the reason hawke says this line about
resolve is because you know the number
three hero has agreed
to go into hiding until horse can take
down the villains
this raises two questions though number
one is who's that person in the bag
and number two is why did hawks take out
the feather sword
in this moment to answer that first
question genus himself would have played
a big role in who was in that bag
when dabi first saw this body he briefly
doubted whether this really was best
genus
but ultimately he didn't care because
hawks had still killed someone
regardless
based on dabby's words here it's highly
likely that this is a real person
and not just some kind of best genius
doll or something like that
like it is real i mean you can tell the
difference between a real body and
something that's completely fake
so i'd assume dabi has you know enough
intelligence to work out the difference
being the righteous hero of the years i
doubt genus would be cool with killing
an innocent person in his place
so i think it's possible they did the
following instead
at this time hawks was not being
monitored by the villains alright this
was before
a skeptic put in all those cameras and
everything so hortz could do whatever he
wanted
and as illustrated by this handy diagram
top heroes have an extensive reach when
it comes to the hero commission
therefore he was still free to contact
the hero commission
and tell them of the current situation
my working theory
right now is that by pulling some
strings the hero commission were able to
acquire a body of a recently deceased
person
that has a similar stature to best genus
at which point
genus used his excellent set of skills
to give that person
a makeover so they resembled him as much
as humanly possible
that way no one was actually killed to
fulfill the mission
and the only real sacrifice was that the
number three hero
had to postpone his return to hero
activities
regarding why hawks took out the feather
sword in this moment is pretty
understandable when you look at the
whole situation
the fact remains that in this moment we
now know that hawks must have told genus
about the plan to kill another hero
and he doesn't know how best genius is
going to react in another reality
genus could have restrained hawkes right
there and then and also maybe he could
have been like no
like i want to return as a hero i'm not
going to hide away for several months
until you finish your plan
you know there's a lot of different
reasons why genus would have declined
the offer
and things could have turned ugly it was
only because of his resolve
that the mission was able to progress
the way it did but on the flip side
genius could have just as easily
declined and then who knows what could
have happened
it's highly likely that he pulled out
this sword for protection
in case genus reacted badly to what
hawks had said
but with that said i'm going to give my
take on why i would have preferred that
this was a real death
and then we'll theorize about what could
happen going forward
best genus's supposed death at the hands
of hawks
happened totally off-screen which always
leaves room for characters to survive
however him really being dead would have
shown hawks's dedication to the mission
and why the hero commission specifically
chose him for the job
someone like endeavour or or might or
anyone else
like no one would have the resolve to
kill another hero
and i thought that this added a layer of
intrigue to hawks's character
and put him in a special grey area of
willing to do evil things
for the greater good additionally while
genus is a top hero
he's not exactly a main character so him
being eliminated off-screen
wouldn't have been that bad from our
perspective as an audience
we also know that bakago wanted genus to
be the first person
who he told his hero name to and the
idea that he'd never get this
opportunity
would have been kind of cool because
like in the real world
things we plan to happen don't exactly
follow a straight path
sometimes random occurrences will mess
things up completely
and that's what it would have been like
if genus was truly dead
let me know what you guys think
bakugou's reaction would have been if
hawks had really killed best genus
do you think he'd be more angry or sad
or would he understand hawke's reasoning
that it was done
for the greater good finally we saw from
dabby's statement when he saw the body
that there was always an element of
doubt about whether this was really
genus
but for me and for people who thought
the same way that i did
i thought the harukoshi was going to
avoid the fake death trope
and this line from dabi was more of a
misdirection sometimes it is good to
subvert expectations
and have an off-screen death that is
actually legit for once
especially as it would have made things
much more interesting when it comes to
dabby revealing the secrets that he's
been hiding
ultimately i do like genus so i'm happy
to see that he is alive
but you know like for all the reasons i
just said it would have been better in
my opinion if this was
for real if he was actually gone moving
on though
as far as the future goes genus will
likely use the fiber from this jet
to try and restrain machia but there's a
big problem at the moment
it doesn't make sense to use the fiber
while still in the jet because there
could be a big risk of the jet crashing
if machia was to lash out so instead
he's going to have to get the cables
down on the ground first
to get them on the ground and actually
use them on machia
that means he has to be ahead of machia
he can't be behind him because it he
can't do anything
so given that the beast is currently
traveling at 100 kilometers per hour
it'll be really difficult to surpass him
but let's see what happens
as we all know bakugou is gravely
injured on the battlefield right now
so it should be a touching moment when
genus finally arrives after
several months missing and we hopefully
get that hero name reveal
from back ago anyway those are my
thoughts on the fate of best genus
let me know your take down below and
until the next one peace out